aplausos de pie para la única película
del áfrica sub sahariana que compite por
la palma de oro en cannes lingua mohamad
saleh harún el director es un conocido
de cannes que en el año 2010 se llevó el
gran premio del jurado y que ha traído a
la crosse de los grandes problemas
sociales de su país el abandono del
padre la guerra civil e incluso el sida
en lingua habla de la historia de una
mujer cuya hija adolescente queda
embarazada producto de una violación
pero ella quiere abortar ese niño en un
país donde se prohíbe el aborto y además
donde la religión también se opone a la
interrupción del embarazo una película
que habla sobre todo de la / ayuda entre
las mujeres y sino la otra alfombra roja
de este día fue para una película que
está fuera de competición con el
hollywoodense matt damon y la actriz de
moda en francia camino total estilo un
water